all right my little Zippity dude as we
finally reached the end that's right I
know I normally dedicate a video to each
Arc individually but since there were
only six volumes left and the last two
arcs are kind of on the short side not
that there's anything wrong with that I
figured it was a good opportunity to not
drag this series out artificially so you
guys are getting two arcs in one video
and seeing as I want to talk about
everything in this video I'm not going
to belabor this intro I saw that a lot
of you guys were saying that you prefer
this chapter black stuff more than Dark
Tournament and that just got me even
more excited and without spoiling
anything right off the bat I can kind of
see why let's kick this video off with
my review and thoughts of the incredibly
well-conceived and fresh chapter
[Music]
black I can't exactly make any judgment
calls on the quality of the overall Arc
just yet but after three volumes of
demon related Shenanigans the very first
page of this new arc promises something
entirely new which is on its own a
terrific and intriguing start and what's
more is tagashi isn't afraid to jump
right into the action all the while
retaining a shroud of mystery humans
have started to prop up with strange
powers and before yusuke is conscripted
into investigating the matter he's
kidnapped by said humans hi Kurama
kurabara and Bolan now are tasked with
locating the kidnappers in order to save
yusuke which is the complete opposite of
what we've gotten used to so far and
they establish all of that in just the
first two chapters the pacing is
outstanding here but what grabbed me
about this opening is how it effectively
achieves two things right off the bat
much of this act will be focused on a
specific trait yusuke has his impatience
and inability to not barge into a fight
unprepared granted he didn't know that
these kids he ran into were going to
cause him trouble but he the winner of
the Dark Tournament ends up being
kidnapped by this guy called keto and
his friends anyway so being blindsided
isn't exactly the best excuse for
someone of his caliber and with that we
established the running goal of this Arc
for yusuke to overcome this flaw and to
grow from it it's excellent stuff but
there's more this arc's opening is one
of the most interesting and engaging to
me because with yusuke now out of the
picture the dynamic within the group of
hi kabara ban and Kurama is now entirely
different to anything we've seen before
it feels so fresh and exciting as all of
these personalities get to take turns
occupying the spotlight in their own
pursuit of yusuke once bten brings them
all together for this purpose speaking
of so I might have said that the intro
to this Arc was awesome and top tier but
uh forget that I I was an idiot I spoke
too soon because this next stuff is even
better and it might be even my favorite
sequence in this series from a writing
or dialogue standpoint or at the very
very least it highlights what is so
wonderful and exciting about the ark to
come as our four Heroes Mosey on inside
to try to find their kid kidnapped MC we
encounter the first of three individuals
they need to overcome someone whom
Kurama is familiar with a kid called Kao
this AR promised a lot with its initial
premise humans suddenly possessing
strange and mysterious Powers but
promise is all fun and dandy but
eventually you will have to back it up
by delivering something worthwhile that
is what this fight is worthwhile to say
the least it's togashi's proof of
concept and I don't think I could have
conceived of a better way to go about
things so much of what makes this Arc so
fun and interesting is of course the
mystery surrounding each encounter 90%
of the fights in this Arc are entirely
different to anything you'll see at any
other point in this story up until now
shown in stories like one piece Dragon
Ball Naruto and even Hunter Hunter all
establish Power Systems and slowly build
on those over time but this Arc it feels
like a coming together of two entirely
different stories we have of course our
collection of main characters and
supporting characters with all the
things that we know that they can do but
we also have these human characters now
that are propping up everywhere with
strange and interesting new abilities
and this first fight against Kaio
demonstrates that through he initially
he treats this encounter with the
relaxed Kaio who's waiting patiently in
this room with the same level of caution
he would any other fight up until now
and that's exactly why he's the first
taken out it appears kaito's power
called Tabo grants him the ability to
establish verbal rules those within his
vicinity need to adhere to if they break
those rules they get their souls stolen
by kaido and just like that suddenly
physical fighting doesn't matter
suddenly this is now a battle of wits a
contest that feels equal parts YuYu Haka
show and a contemporary series at the
time like JoJo's bazarre Adventure these
really could be a series of stand
battles straight out of part three and I
wouldn't be surprised if they were
inspired by it given JoJo's huge Surge
and popularity at the time with he being
taken out easily towards the beginning
of this encounter tagashi is once again
reinforced the theme of you need to
prepare a strategy before just barging
into a conflict the word that he said
that triggered his Soul's Rapture was
hot and so following this after some
funny kabara suggestions to leave he and
move on the game becomes who can avoid
saying the word hot the longest
[Music]
feeling trapped in a situation that
demands those that participate follow a
set of clearly established rules as the
game progresses we learn more and more
of the finer details of those rules and
kaido's Powers alak kabara losing his
soul by saying the word shots a word
which contains the word hot but by the
end only kaido and Kurama remain eager
to take things to the next level in
terms of difficulty Kurama makes a
suggestion or Amendment to the current
rules for kaido to implement but what
makes us lean in here is that during
this suggestion he adds that he'll
defeat Kaio in just 26 minutes and
that's when I had this thought damn this
might be the most compelling Kurama
encounter I've experienced in this manga
I love mind games like this and perhaps
it's the reprieve I'm getting from the
action carrying this thought for me but
I truly loved this encounter he very
much feels like the common collected
jotoro to kaito's Darby The Gambler
praying on his ego manufacturing a way
to dictate terms in an arrangement he
truthfully has no power in and if you
thought 26 minutes was a suspicious
number you'd be right for every minute
that passes a letter from the alphabet
will be removed from play it's a super
fun concept and one that lends itself
well to tension and humor this encounter
far exceeded my wildest expectations
Togashi is incredibly talented as the
time ticks on by Kito gets nervous and
with only one letter remaining Kurama is
nowhere to be seen
when
that was awesome okay time to move on to
the next section this is the final
segment of this introduction to this Ark
and how it works and while not as
compelling as the prior I still very
much enjoyed it I think I didn't have as
much fun with this one as the mystery
surrounding the encounter gets lifted
shortly after which is hardly a
criticism of tashi's writing here as
it's more a desire of mind for this
segment to never end following the
watchful eye of one of the trio Our Gang
each Ascend a flight of stairs in the
hopes of reaching the room keto is
holding yusuke hostage they all seem to
arrive on the scene but as Kido makes
yusuke aware one of them is a fake o
exciting this is another amazing mind
game from tagashi and one which shifts
our perspective back to yusuke with Yus
having only 10 minutes to decipher the
fake he spends the entire 10 minutes
getting absolutely nowhere of worth
which you know is incredible work and in
the end he ends up pulling a volume one
yusuke move and just decking kabara
seemingly at random and
happening to be right now I know what
you're thinking and to be honest I was
thinking the same thing too initially
was this a Devolution of the UK
character was Togashi falling back on
luck as the key factor which decided
yusuke's conflicts thankfully no there's
a key difference in how this conclusion
is presented that really shows how
farashi has come in writing this manga
you see while yusuke does initially pay
it off like it was dumb luck it is
immediately revealed that there were
some reasonably sound logic bits behind
this decision he knew Kurama and hi were
too strong to get easily nabbed for the
stunt and that the enemies would know
nabbing botan would send yusuke into a
very dangerous fit of rage leaving only
kabara as a prime Contender it's solid
logic or at least solid enough for me
either way the vibe of this success by
luck instance feels so much better than
the ones that plague the early chapters
of the series this isn't the writing of
an inexperienced author unsure of how to
end a fight it's one with conf Intent no
unearned victories No Lack of character
in the path to success none of that we
still get the laugh of I owed kabara one
without any of the disappointing
deflation hooray for everybody however
as it happens this introductory series
of challenges was just that an
introduction to the broader reach of
this story and with one panel Tashi
forces us all to lean in because Genai
is back and was behind the entire
sequence from the get-go oh no Tashi
revealing that this was all just an
elaborate prank by Gen Kai feels a
little deflating considering how much
tension was built up earlier but to be
honest that's a minor fleeting gripe for
me I really enjoyed the introduction to
this Arc so much of it focused on
character Centric challenges to the cast
rather than just fists and blasts and
thankfully that is in fact a trend
that's carried forward through much of
this Arc and at the very least agashi is
kind of upfront about gen Kai's renewed
existence in the story that is to
exposit I mean introduce the real
problem that is unfolding here and it's
right here where we're made aware of the
main focus of the Ark itself that
there's a giant gate to the demon realm
being opened up someone has carried on
sako's wishes and this demonic portal is
widening by the hour but the most
interesting Wrinkle in this I think is
the introduction of demon ranks to the
story the reveal that demons are ranked
D to S and that toguro the Unstoppable
Beast of just a few chapters ago is a
mere rank B well it is just bound to get
the mind racing with questions and
excitement creating a wonderful
anticipation in the process this has
been done already in Dragon Ball with
power levels and this letter ranking
system was even used much later to great
success in one punchman it's a
wonderfully effective narrative tool my
first thought here was that the higher
ranks didn't make much sense given how
lauded over toguro was as one of the
baddest tough guys to ever tough around
in the entire demon Community but
thankfully Togashi not only addresses
that concern but uses it to further
deepen the intrigue and mystery
surrounding the ark itself it is
explained that rank A and S demons dwell
exclusively in the deepest darkest
Plains of the demon realm and are
completely unable to cross over into the
human world or interact with just about
anyone outside of their own planes for
many of the b-class demons and Below
these highest tiers of demons are just
as much myth as they are for humans
their power is so far beyond what the
lower ranks can even comprehend or reach
that the two may as well be completely
unrelated now that's what I call a
compelling fail State the goal and
Stakes of this Arc are set up and
Crystal Clear from the get-go and that
fact alone can help drive a story
incredibly well with only three weeks of
time to work with the team minus he who
is too much of a grumpy grumblin to give
a [__] splits into two with kurama's
crew investigating the hole itself and
use cas's crew immediately heading off
to swarm City the affected City to
investigate for Clues well that is as
soon as they remember kaido is still
soulless along the way yusuke's crew
manages to recruit morota another
mutated human who wire tap ability
allows him to read mines a useful asset
for the team in the future but honestly
the most important bit here is this
singular panel of yusuke's inner
monologue that I could look at 10,000
times and still laugh at whaty guy the
real result of this addition to the
party however is the scene that follows
morota is used as a sort of search
Beacon sifting through the thoughts of
anyone within a 30 m radius trying to
find the ring leader of this portal
opening business and the moment he does
locate him
[Music]
now that was creepy the way the manga in
particular depicts this is simply
chilling the reader is placed alongside
our heroes in a position of control and
security covertly and undetected WE peer
into the minds of others with the
understanding that we are the ones
getting the drop on them that we have
the element of surprise and that
chilling fear emanates from the page
when it's revealed that we were mistaken
that we are not in control he is the
immediate turn toward the camera the
uneven hatching detailing on the face
the pace of the entire thing is all
contained within a single page three
panels no less and made it clear to me
in seconds that this guy is not only
creepy but entirely in control a control
he possesses thanks in part two careful
preparation and strategy those of you
following along will see why this is
important but for now let's move on from
here the goal is establishing is done
we've moved to a hospital and morota has
recovered enough to relay a few bits of
information he got from sensui amidst
all of the other insane inner monologue
seven names all likely indicative of
their abilities Dark Angel gatekeeper
sniper Gourmet game master doctor and
Seaman Sean and with that all the cards
for this Arc are officially down creepy
man and a Sinister set of seven super
villains are all opening a hole to the
deepest reaches of the demon realm and
if yusuke and Co can't defeat them all
and stop it then class s demons with
strength Untold will flood into Earth
and everyone will die it sounds pretty
straightforward when you spell it out
like that but everything is shrouded in
so much mystery and revealed in such an
interesting fashion that I was hooked
all the way through now of course it
doesn't take long before one of those
seven members makes himself known as an
evil entity has suddenly expanded his
territory in the hospital now class it's
time for some group participation
which of the seven members do you think
would be in the hospital is it a seaman
b game master or C doctor if you
answered C doctor then congratulations
you're smarter than these dumb asses
once again though this Arc establishes
its encounter as far more than just who
can punch who harder because not only is
the doctor letting loose a swarm of
demon mosquitoes that afflict a terrible
sickness as well as having hands that
cut like scalpel but the doctor himself
is hiding in plain sight in the hospital
after splitting up to look for Clues
keto the shadow user manages to stumble
upon the doctor early on but is
instantly paralyzed left only to watch
on in horror yusuke overhears This
calamity and rushes into the scene but
that doesn't really do much when the
only living witness is now paralyzed
this begins a fascinating game where
Kido and yusuke have to manage to work
together despite an inability to
communicate and this really is a prime
example of how ingenious these human
mutated powers are on tashi's part they
become not just vessels for different
types of combat but a utility to create
fascinating and compelling scenarios
this is nail binding stuff as the killer
doctor is inches from yusuke but in one
of the sickest moves to date keto is
able to use his shadow powers to prevent
yusuke from mistakenly giving Chase
elsewhere that on its own is such an
utterly ingenious use of the tools at
the character's disposal but the
creative Innovation doesn't stop there
that play is enough to communicate to
yusuke that he's conscious and something
is up but not who the threat is
necessarily through a tumultuous inner
monologue on keto's part he finally
manages to arrive at the only solution
left available to him by moving his
shadow he spells out the name of the
doctor in Disguise now come on that's
just brilliant it's such a wonderfully
tense Visual and an incredible way to
have the ball drop on yusuke in a world
where air Arc ago it felt like the
powers and restrictions of the world
were set in stone Togashi manages AR
over AR to bre new life into this story
it's the sort of cerebral and clever
writing I found in JoJo as arachi began
to expand on stand encounters to see
that filtered through to gashi is
amazing the doctor even strikes a JoJo
pose with all that said the dynamic in
this fight is once again novel and
unique often times in these Shonen
stories once the training is done and
the big bad is defeated in the prior Arc
things sort of reset and the hero once
again finds himself in in over his head
despite how competent the main character
became in the prior Arc but here yusuke
is as capable as he has ever been he has
Superman speed and power not to mention
his ray gun and the doctor isn't
inexplicably strong because the story
demanded it he's simply enhanced by the
powers that he has in specific
believable ways believable ways that he
as an enemy entirely leans into the
doctor cannot land a single attack but
what he can do is prolong the fight by
manipulating his nerve system and having
established that all of his friends will
die in less than 10 minutes thanks to
the virus he Unleashed it's a potent
plan to say the least particularly
against someone like yusuke who has the
power to stop him but he needs
information and doesn't want to kill him
in the end the doctor actually manages
to succeed over yusuke in a way as
yusuke is forced to kill him saving
everyone infected by the mosquito demons
not All Is Lost though as Genai is able
to use some of her good oldfashioned
spirit healing business to resuscitate
the doctor where he is now left to play
a future role at this point two days
have now passed and kenma shows up to
use some geometry no Jutsu to explain
how the timeline is actually one week
rather than two but more importantly
both for my own personal enjoyment as
well as the plot kabara is ducking out
of the upcoming Mission not because he's
scared or out mashed or anything like
that but because he has tickets to a
Metallica I mean magelica
concert how's that one week I'm using it
first of all let me just say that
abandoning saving the world to see a
live show is extremely valid kabara I
hear and understand you life without
music is indeed not worth living but
second while the whole sequence is
obviously funny and partially played for
Laughs it actually hides Togashi
performing some sneaky Pawn
repositioning for the story itself the
following sequence is where Seaman it's
not Seaman it's Sean makes himself known
but the target isn't Yus the target is
kabara of whom has now made himself
completely alone and largely defenseless
as his Ora still hasn't recovered with
he still doing Gremlin activities Kurama
still off investigating and yusuke to
annoy a kuara to have followed his
worried instincts kabara finds himself
completely isolated easy pickings for
Seaman it's Sean who very clearly
outmatches kabara in his current state
unlike the previous matches in this Arc
this encounter is no test of wit or
skill it's really a test of how stubborn
kabara is willing to be and how many
times he can insult the enemy along the
way even when utterly beaten his friends
taken hostage in the middle of droning
against an enemy stand and facing a
seemingly unbeatable foe kabara just
refuses to stop swinging it's a trait
that he's always carried with him
throughout the story but most every
occasion he ended up being backed up by
his companions or spurred them through
new heights but this time there's no
companion to rise up it's only him
until
this entire section is plotted so
deceptively well that it's kind of nuts
Kara has struggled to find his place in
the world for a while now especially
since yusuke achieved New Heights in the
Dark Tournament Arc with so many
powerful and talented allies at yusuke's
side now what role is kabara left to
play but the Damsel in Distress who
Spurs yusuke to Greater Heights but this
time the payoff isn't yusuke arriving
and kicking ass it's kabara achieving
New Heights while also carving out a
whole unique Niche for himself in this
plot being the long sought after man who
can split Dimensions this not only
places kabara back in a precarious role
as sensu and Co need that very talent to
finish the Demonic portal but also once
again carves out a unique position for
kabara to play in the early days it was
his strong Sixth Sense and now it is
this as a certified kabara fan you can
color me excited and very pleased with
this outcome as if this encounter
weren't already surprisingly pivotal
enough the Thematic undertone for the
enemies finally begins to rear its head
throughout the arc so far each of the
enemies has had a clear lack of humanity
and outright disdain for their own human
race it's somehow even more vitriolic
than the default hate for humans that
all the previous demons had showcased
and with caman AKA Koshi it was no
different however when kabara defeated
Sean accepting his fate he waited for a
swift death but to his surprise it never
came after all he's done despite his own
damning words kabara wasn't going to
kill him because he wanted to use what
he knows to save more people the
confusion plastered across kyoshi's face
here during this interaction just says
it all there's a dissonance created a
core belief that was beginning to
shatter the core belief it turns out
originates from the titular Arc defining
chapter black or black chapter as the
English manga puts it a VHS tape of
Humanity's darkest most cruel and
depraved acts throughout history history
naturally it doesn't take much
imagination to envisage what sort of
imagery that tape contained in fact some
of it is repeated by Koshi in great
detail this tape is the core reason
behind each of the seven members of the
senu group and has very clearly
instilled in them a feeling of utter
disgust and helplessness in the world
forgive me for the detour here but as I
read this entire exchange I was all but
overcome with just well just how
important and relevant these themes are
to this very day in modern times it is
seemingly impossible to go about our
lives at all ages without bearing
witness to orders of atrocities that we
see online the information age that we
find ourselves in now has given us
unbridled wisdom insight and well
information but it has also made it near
impossible to avoid seeing just how bad
the world and Humanity can be ethnic
cleansing drone strike after drone
strike political assassinations gang
violence epidemics of poverty and
homeless
starvation of children when there is
plenty to go around even the very planet
in which we all live on seems to be all
but doomed stricken by the seemingly
Unstoppable parasite that is the human
Race's desire for more seeing all of
this thrust Upon Us each and every year
is understandably hard for some people
to not lose hope with to not give in the
nihilistic views of the world and feel
that all is already lost that we don't
deserve to be there that the human race
is is a plague the machines that cause
the atrocities are unstoppable so why
care but tagashi and the YuYu Haka show
crew by extension totally rejects this
Outlook because and I totally agree with
this hopelessness is easy seeing the
world for what it is and giving into
nothingness is not enlightened it's easy
and dare I say almost selfish each and
every person has to some capacity the
ability to make some part of the world a
better place we might not know how to
fix all the problems just yet but in the
same way evil people exist there too are
and will continue to be more good people
people like Dr Philip Frank stter and
Colin Ure who along with their team
created small saches that went added to
the nastiest water you can find managed
to separate the clean drinking water in
seconds it's like magic and breeds a
quality of life to the African world
that's stricken with water poverty or
how about Dutch inventor boy and slat
who engineered an incredibly effective
way to not only clean up a tremendous
amount of the Earth's oceans but has
also many plans in place to prevent them
from being polluted into the future this
is all to say that giving into despair
is too easy but looking at it in the
face and marching forward even if you
don't have an answer at this exact
moment that's true bravery Meeting Evil
with kindness and hope is all we can do
and it's exactly what yusuke chooses to
do in the face of all of this it's the
perfect message he himself even says he
has no idea what to tell Kyoshi at this
moment of his despair but he chooses to
move forward and do the best that he can
in the best way that he can do it and I
think that is something every single kid
every single person on the planet right
now should read and honestly needs to
hear
okay with that detour out of the way
Togashi resumes layering even more
Intrigue onto the story with the reveal
that sensui was once a spirit detective
yusuke's predecessor no less a spirit
detective with a strong sense of justice
who encountered a group of utterly vile
humans and was never able to properly
reconcile with that incident and with
that I think Togashi has officially
checked pretty much every possible box
for setting up an arc its villains its
motivations its thematic through lines
everything upon this Arc Togashi has
built an infinitely solid foundation and
I could not be more excited to keep
reading from this point on the momentum
of this Arc picks up and never really
stops senu and snipers show up having
bugged seen stop it leaving both yusuke
and kabara to storm in and attack them
as you might expect that doesn't go
particularly well for them with yusuke
totally outclassed with his head on
approach to fighting sensui and kabara
sneakily kidnapped by a guy who ate
Elder toguro to steal his power even
yusuke's full power spiron just gets
batted Away by sensui like it's nothing
once again these two kiddos ran head
first into an encounter and suffered the
consequences so how does yusuke react to
this
well yeah no he just gets even angrier
and rushes them at mach five on a
bicycle okay so that's fantastic stuff I
can't imagine this will end poorly at
all uh once again it doesn't take long
for the rash Behavior to yield dire
consequences needless to say yusuke is
quickly pinpointed by sniper who is able
to put magic Targets on him allowing
sniper to launch any object at yusuke at
high speeds from any distance my man
just cannot catch a break here but again
he can't catch a break specifically
because he refuses to stop and think and
as a result yusuke is having rocks
needles a whole ass truck thrown at him
on a whim and frankly yusuke once again
gets completely owned outright or at
least that would have been the case if
not
[Applause]
four nothing Personnel kid our cool
little Gremlin boy is back not only is
he a here to save yusuke's ass but also
proves to be the only sensible child of
the lot as yusuke tries to once again
Dash head first towards sensui and yeah
he basically tells him how stupid he's
being and starts beating the [__] out of
him with kuara captured and only two
days till the portal is complete what
did I tell you about the insane momentum
of the story yusuke and crew have a near
impossible task laid out before them at
this point we reached the endgame punt
absolutely intended as the entire crew
matches upon the enemy lir and
encounters the first of the remaining
Enemies game master similar to the
abstract house at the beginning of the
AR game master has enshrouded the entire
room in a condition that only the winner
of game battler a video game that is
just a matchup of real world video games
can emerge from the room unfortunately
this section is the first this Arc
really stumbled for me because while the
situation is very similar to the
abstract house and Kaio every way that
it tries to expand upon that idea just
sort of makes it worse with kaido and
his word game the rules were simple and
presented in a way that the readers
could follow along with it led to a
gripping exchange where each Twist and
Turn of strategy left us wondering where
to go like we were right beside Kurama
but here none of that really applies the
first three games are mostly skipped
over with them being written as such a
footnote that it left me wondering why
they were all even shown in the first
place outside of a minor character
development moment for kyoshi's one
outing but that still doesn't explain
the other two but then with the trivia
game it is purposely something we as
readers aren't able to follow along with
the trivia is totally foreign to us and
game master strategy of learning the
question algorithm just leaves us
further out of the loop and yet the
conclusion to this lackluster series of
games somehow manages to be one of the
darkest and emotionally moving parts of
the story so far what seemed to be a
game of Simply indefinitely stalling
yusuke until the portal is complete is
revealed to be a trap for both parties
orchestrated by sensui The Mastermind
and ring leader of all of this because
in the video game game battler while
losing results is a try again State
winning results results in the death of
the boss which means either game master
continues to win and keep yusuke at Bay
or he dies this is the exact sort of
mental pressure that team yusuke needed
to overcome him but at this point that
isn't really the problem is it since we
abused a child's naivity and led him to
an almost guaranteed demise the final
unsolvable conundrum is the fate of this
deeply misled child crumbling under the
realization of his mistake he begs
through tears for a way out out of his
inescapable death the paneling of these
final moments is Stark and harrowing and
the illustration of Kurama afterwards
pens so intricately with togashi's
signature brush is an impression that
will stay with me for a very long time
to come despite starting out Rocky this
sequence really managed to find its
footing and in the end left me with one
of the strongest Impressions this series
and certainly this Arc has offered I'm
very much enjoying how prominent a role
Kurama is playing in this Arc after our
gang arrives at the portal it's revealed
that one of the remaining seven that
seems to possess the powers of the
eldest Togo brother was in fact him in
Disguise all along oh son of a [__] or
rather that the Elder Togo being eaten
didn't matter much because he just uh
took over the host anyway I don't know
but either way it's metal as all hell
and Kurama takes the lead on tackling
him which makes sense as ultimately
Kurama is really the most important
chess piece Togashi has at his disposal
in this Arc right now for an arc whose
theming is very clearly centered around
growing use is maturity and forcing him
to think before he acts who better to
contrast against him and exemplify the
advantages of those virtues than the
humble and calculated Kurama in more
ways than one he represents the goal for
him when yusuke is barging ahead he's
investigating when yusuke is backed into
a corner yusuke needs to rely on others
or he gets soundly defeated whereas
Kurama remains Cal and overcomes when
the odds are tipping out of favor if
there's one thing about Kurama in this
Arc that's apparent is that he's rarely
ever call off G to such an extent he
becomes vulnerable he's an
uncompromisingly stoic and calculated
individual heard the promise he made
prior kuara is returned to yusuke but in
a show of control and force he's quickly
extracted from the arena the fighting
has been taking place within along with
everyone else except yusuke this
encounter sets up the final segment of
the story and with it it brings to the
Forefront a contest between yusuke and
Sensi and it might be more well
conceived of than you might appreciate
at first glance on three fronts this
fight Works to serve the yusuke
character historically emotionally and
mechanically within the narrative from a
historical point of view this outing
offers us the surface level chance to
enjoy what a fight looks like between
two spirit detectives and as
similarities often do differences are
emphasized mechanically the story of
this Arc is yusuke's journey to gain
maturity in combat through our
historical understanding of the
character we can recognize that this
might not be something that comes
naturally to yusuke but it nevertheless
is something he ultimately needs to
learn as he grows older and who better
to push him to this goal than his
proverbial opposite where yusuke rushes
in all guns blazing sensui is a Cool Cam
and calculated enemy one who has had
yusuke as well as seemingly the majority
of his allies trapped in his web for the
duration of this Arc without them his
plan could never have succeeded quite
literally and since we played them all
beautifully in order to defeat this
competent opponent yusuke now needs to
follow what others have been telling him
what Gen Kai has been advising him he
needs to remain Cam and formulate a
clear plan of attack which brings us to
the most resonant difference between the
two characters their emotional
differences this might be the most
compelling difference and it's an
element of their characters I've only
recently become privy to and in a way
proves that not only is yusuke right for
this role as a spirit detective but when
it comes to temperament and
philosophical Outlook sensui was doomed
to fail from the start I spoke on this
earlier but there's a pattern of
behavior and a nihilistic worldview at
play here that colors each and every
decision sensui and his followers make a
disgust for Humanity viewing the world
in naive absolutes he sees people as
black and white because of this he was
unable to see past Humanity's admittedly
horrific indiscretions and thus
concluded he's responsible for ending
the plague on the earth that is Humanity
it's an interesting concept and one
perfect for a villain but it's made all
the more interesting when you consider
what yusuke offers as a foil to him
where since we was a model citizen
yusuke operates in the gray area areas
of morality however and this is
important yusuke is still a good person
made evident by the countless Good Deeds
he's committed on behalf of others while
sensui represents everything on a
strategic front that yusuke needs to
learn yusuke on the other hand possesses
the positive and hopeful outlook on life
that sees value in humanity where seni
constructed a carefully curated plan
willing to March countless of his own
pawns to their deaths in the name of
this great mission yusuke on the other
hand without thinking has proven to be
selfless to a fault sacrificing himself
in the name of a small child he didn't
even
know but I do have my issues with this
fight there's a rather impactful page
following yusuke's first strike on
sensui in it he says to me fighting has
always been an end in itself that I get
to take on threats to the human world is
just icing on the cake what this is a
cool line and one that speaks to the
differences in both men's approaches to
the job they have/ had I feel like this
to a certain extent is the first
instance of flanderization in this
series while yusuke does indeed love to
fight and often seeks it out that
doesn't Define him to refer to saving
others as quote icing on the cake I feel
sort of betrays what his character has
grown to represent in the series from
the very first chapter he's demonstrated
a need to save others sacrificing his
own life at a moment's notice and by
extension giving up every opportunity to
fight into the future all to save a
single small child that's a powerful
moment that defined his character early
on and one that was only further
reinforced in the Dark Tournament Arc as
he found his reason to fight there were
no doubt be folks in the comments right
now that will be telling me it's not
that deep or that I'm reading too much
into this and perhaps I should just take
this as the cool page that it is and
leave it at that but for whatever reason
I just didn't like how this dialogue hit
my years it simplifies the character yes
but to a degree I felt made him less
interesting and betrayed who I thought
he was in the first place something
however rather interesting happens as
this fight commences and evolves towards
its resolution there's some fitting
characterization some brilliant
symbolism and unfortunately signs of
things to come that I will dig into in
more detail later on now as I said a
massive component to this story taking
place in this Arc is the growth of
yusuke's character and his ability to
strategize
and Sen we plays into this wonderfully
with himself not necessarily being
stronger than yusuke but due to his
approach is still able to gain the upper
hand possessing the ability to foresee
his opponent's moves might seem
convoluted and rather strange to reveal
at this juncture but when you consider
it really plays into the lessons yusuke
needs to overcome it feels perfectly
fitting to add as a hurdle for the young
man to try and navigate here however
probably my favorite element to this
initial part of the sensory versus
yusuke fight is how well Togashi
combines yusuke's natural Rog demeanor
with fitting strategy to get the drop on
sensui the aspect of yusuke that makes
him Incorruptible compared with sensui
his delinquent Behavior acts as his
Saving Grace allowing him to fight dirty
kicking up dust to work around sensory's
guard using his clothing to restrict his
movement crude but fitting strategy for
a kid like yusuke to utilize it's very
reminiscent of the sort of crude but
Street Savvy approach yusuke used in the
first Arc with his lighter it's not
pretty but it gets the job done and I
love that it's perfect for him and while
the Fight Continues to build higher and
higher leading eventually to Revelations
I'm still honestly processing the rest
of this fight's progression began to
lose me and more importantly began to
betray yusuke's character at its core
shinobu sensui was a perfect foil for
yusuke in this Arc and complemented its
themes excellently to boot but more than
that we had really begun to know him and
now at the final hour we are finding out
that he is actually said
guys and has a gun
[Music]
arm okay now I don't want to be down in
this story because truth be told from
the very first Arc all the way through
to this point I felt like this series
was going from strength to strength
however while I don't want to be overly
negative I also can't fabricate the
feelings I have towards this fight now
because I genuinely do see issues here
kenma arrives for a few minutes to step
in but doesn't achieve much yusuke
outright says that he doesn't care about
about the portal anymore and that he's
only there for the fight something that
I would argue objectively flies in the
face of not only the mission statement
of this Arc and what Gen Kai wants to
teach him but also betrays the core
Foundation of his character Al so that
we can do what have a big dumb
[Music]
fight one of the few elements that
remains consistent in this arc's
conclusion is The Supporting Cast
thankfully particularly kabara who leaps
to action when yusuke is pronounced dead
during the fight which I honestly love
cutting a tear in reality Landing them
all in the demon plane to face off once
again but honestly it all feels too
little too late to me and all this talk
of strategy feels like it goes right out
the window too characters like Kurama
who in the past represented clever and
cunning strategies to overcome opponents
in more advantageous positions now are
seen saying things like and I quote he's
stronger than we are at this moment but
that's all it takes to
win okay like this is literally the
exact opposite opposite of what we were
being told all this time what he's been
telling us all this time both directly
and indirectly and regrettably The Arc
only Falls further from this point
devolving into a fight that feels almost
like a caricature of what Shonen
actually is lots of actions seemingly
for Action sake all the way down to
sudden Transformations that feel like
they jumped the shark honestly this
sudden shift felt Stark to me and it did
my team too when they were collectively
reading it eventually we all stumbled
across this Q&A with Togashi where and
he was asked and I quote what was the
most painful thing that happened while
you were writing yuu Haka show and one
of the two instances he mentioned was
this very fight with sensory in it he
says that during the final battle he
didn't want to draw the manga anymore
and that he felt nauseous at the thought
of just sitting down to draw it is so
clear both on the pages as well as in
his interviews that Togashi was battling
with his medical issues hard at this
point but rather than take a break and
finish the arc when he could do it
justice he just had to trudge on and
make do an approach that ultimately cost
the most promising Arc yet its
conclusion the overall message of Good
and Evil nihilism versus hope everything
contained within most of this Arc really
is what I think is both powerful and
compelling and I really did love reading
most of this Arc but that is exactly why
I'm so bummed by how it ended upon this
story Togashi had built an invincibly
sturdy Foundation but I suppose that
does no good when your Foreman can call
out
sick the three kings Ark all right so
let's reset let's take a breath and come
to grips with something before I press
onwards here I know that folks out there
will have already likely commented about
the anime in this section being better
or the definitive way to consume this
story so consider the following as my
address of this concern like I have said
countless times in the past and even
within this very video series the
content of what I am reviewing and
speaking about is specifically to do
with the manga its execution and the
pros and cons all of that experience
it's my understanding that particularly
with this final Arc Tashi for multiple
Reasons I'm sure encountered trouble in
fully realizing it and due to that fact
the anime took Liberties by changing the
story to some degree in order to make a
more coherent narrative experience
because of this many see the anime
version of events as the definitive
version to sight I will not be doing
this my interest for this Series has
squarely resided on the production and
product of the manga itself and
specifically the work of tagashi whether
a vision is successful like the Dark
Tournament Arc or whether it came up
short like maybe this will it's through
examining that process as well as trying
to understand the behind the scenes
going on to make sense of that that I
interested in as a reviewer we use
footage from the anime in these videos
to smooth over the production of this
review series and so with that
disclaimer out of the way let's analyze
what I thought of this final Arc where
chapter black led us into the story with
what was essentially a hold open the
three kings leads us naturally from Arc
to Ark by building upon Revelations from
the prior with yusuke revealed as being
part demon his father having ruined his
big fight and a one-way ticket to the
darkest depths of the demon realm yusuke
is given an ultimatum either stay in the
demon world forever and search for his
demon daddy or return to Earth initially
he chooses to return to the human world
but it's here I'm first impressed with
the framing Togashi has given this Ark
unlike how I anticipated at the
beginning of this section this Arc
doesn't any traditional sense seamlessly
flow from the previous but instead
almost presents a soft reset once yusuke
returns to the human world and it's
actually for a rather inventive reason
all the while establishing A fitting
framing device for this conclusive Arc
normally through soft resetting back to
the status quo W might expect things to
return as they were with yusuke Dawning
his Spirit detective Persona fighting
demons infiltrating the human world Etc
however it can't be that way now because
things are different irreversibly so
yusuke is a demon his heart does not
beat and through all of this inactivity
he's getting bored from a distinct lack
of cases or conflict to engage in in the
human world and with this it tells us
that a certain distance has emerged
between kenma and yusuke through a
meeting with Genai and eventually a
meeting with the first ever Spirit
detective we learned that there are
fears that one day yusuke's boredom
could take the form of thoughtlessly
destroying the world he's too powerful
now and as mentioned in the text his
Humanity seems to be in question here
but perhaps most importantly now he
can't be controlled and so they insist
he returns to the demon plane and for me
this was a rather fascinating turn of
events through offering this Togashi is
presenting yusuke with a very similar
ultimat him to that which he saw at the
beginning of this story either go back
to the human world or remain dead at the
beginning of the story he initially felt
as though he should remain dead seeing
as all the adult figures in his life
pretty much called him a bad kid or a
drain on society that he was nothing but
a negative force in people's lives
ultimately and thankfully he chose to
stay in the human world after he saw
that he did offer value to people's
lives and that he would be missed
however now he finds himself in a
similar situation but under slightly
different contexts similar to the very
beginning he's being pushed away by the
first group to really accept him kenma
and Co they now see him as a demon on
the brink of chaos but it's more
complicated than a simple dilemma here
instead of the motivating factor being
there pushing of him away he's in
addition to that hating to investigate
what's going on with his father and that
activity happens to coincide with the
desires of kenma and his group
overseeing him so will yusuke return
once he makes the decision what will his
reasoning be there's only one way to
find out but at any rate I'm interested
in seeing how yusuke after an entire
series worth of development might have
changed in his approach to answering
these very
questions unfortunately dear viewers it
is at this juncture in which the
increasing issues with the story and
tashi's back evolves into well in to
something I'm I'm honestly not sure I
can even really call what follows an arc
it's honestly one of the most baffling
Crea Adventures I've ever had to
experience now look you might be
thinking I'm exaggerating what I'm
saying this but if you could have only
seen the reactions of both myself and my
team when we were reading this you'd
understand a bit better and if I break
it down I think it's pretty simple to
understand why the story itself starts
off by outlining a 40-hour time limit
that yusuke has to search for his father
in the demon realm a couple chapters
later we're not utilizing that time
restraint at all anymore and instead
we're piecing out back to the human
world to reset the ark softly that's
okay at this point we realize that
yusuke's character is being called into
question because of course it is he
Shadow the Hedgehog now and now he's
heading back to the demon world that we
now can move freely between by the way
so yeah keep up with that in order to
meet with yusuke's dying demon Overlord
of of her father called ryzen This is
why he's doing it from here Togashi
starts to write what appears to be a
political demon Thriller with a battle
on three fronts each one is helmed by
either Kurama hi or yusuke himself a
story of which at this point you can
really tell that tagashi is struggling
either with his health his motivation or
both because the art delivered for all
of this is effectively rough sketches
from this point over a year passes and
yusuke's father dies leaving yusuke to
make the first move in this war at this
point a lot of the pieces have been
moved by Kurama and we've learned a lot
about he's positioning on his side of
the conflict that he's helming but
everything isn't as it seems because
yusuke basically shows up and says
political Thrillers are cringe H yeah
want to do a tournament instead for the
fate of demons and the human world uh
yeah so they all agreed to do this and
so the tournament just gets underway and
oh yeah and uh yomi one of the three
kings he has a son now he's not
important at all but he I think at one
point he was supposed to be the
tournament starts and there's like just
way too many people and I'm getting
worried because we're on the last volume
of manga now and tagashi still has an
entire tournament to write so I start
reading and then I see
this so what this tournament is isn't
really a tournament it isn't really
anything all it is is tagashi skipping
over stuff until
finally how was it it was the greatest
tournament I've ever seen in my life and
you would believe the celebrities who
did cameos Dustin Hoffman Michael
Jackson yeah that's right right when the
biggest fight of the Ark was about to go
down yomi versus yusuke it cuts to
months afterwards and all that's left is
tagashi telling us what happened and if
we ignore the pain tagashi might be in
or the lack of Interest he may have in
completing the story in a vacuum this is
objectively atrocious storytelling and
then it gets weirder because we still
have half a volume of stuff to go from
this point on all that we encounter are
disperate story threads some only a
couple chapters long some only a couple
of pages long all with the sole purpose
of getting us to the finish line of the
series as fast as humanly possible as a
concept I think the notion of returning
back to the episodic nature in the same
way the series began to book end is a
cute idea but in practice it just feels
entirely pointless I pointed out at the
beginning of this series that while I
typically dislike episodic stories there
are ways to get the most out of them in
yuu Haka Show's case tagashi leveraged
the format to warm us all up to the new
characters before we launched into
something more substantial now it feels
like a crutch now it's just worse and
boring after this series of Breakneck
mini plots we finally land on the final
two chapters and thankfully it feels a
lot less frantic it feels almost nice
getting to see everyone together one
last time expressing how they feel in
ways that feel true to their characters
however by this point it was but a
sobering reminder of what could have
been rather than the cherry on what
could have also been a very fun and
captivating cake to call this an arc
presupposes an overarching story that's
held together by a Clear Vision with the
goal of telling a compelling tale and
while this Arc does technically have
structure in places it is ultimately
less like a story and more like the
notes of a struggling artist spiraling
unrestrained and clumsily towards a
conclusion he desperately needs to reach
this Arc feels like tagashi had five sto
stories he wanted to tell and instead of
telling one well he decided to smoosh
them all together and improvise what was
left if manga was music this Arc is free
form Jazz but performed by a sickly
orangutan it certainly has its moments
but my God does this have some choices
and look I might be sounding harsh but I
think the reason I felt this way is
because we know at this point what
Togashi is capable of and what he will
be capable of very soon soon in Hunter
Hunter however I think this Arc if
nothing else possesses something that we
can all take away as a positive for in
the future a lesson that if I were to
have watched the anime I would never
have taken away so do I recommend yuu
Haka show as a manga and story
absolutely I think there's more than
enough terrific storytelling an Artistry
on display to Warrant at the very least
a passing glance despite its ending
feeling quite disjointed and chaotic I
have to say I was massively impressed
with this story by tagashi and what's
more is I think it gave me a whole new
appreciation for Hunter Hunter as a
result for those that didn't watch my
hunter hunter series I effectively
became so overwhelmed by the negativity
I saw permeating the pages I was reading
that it in turn negatively impacted My
overall experience with the manga and my
memory of it so what changed between
then and now well to avoid divulging too
many personal details online I'll just
say that this month my family and I were
stricken with a rather sudden and
shocking loss and within that situation
I was forced to not just navigate that
turmoil but also figure out a way to
manage my own workflow entrenched in the
middle of a review series places a lot
of pressure on output output I wanted to
deliver for you all I considered trying
to deal with both to conduct business as
normal forcing myself to work through
the pain however clearer heads prevailed
and in the end I was fortunate enough to
be able to take a step back delay this
video and lean on the support of my team
to help make up for the difference but
what does this have to do with Hunter
Hunter and tagashi well regrettably
tagashi has become a mangaa famous for
his shortcomings and struggles his
career is defined by his cultural
contributions through series like yuu
Haka show and Hunter Hunter however
almost invariably there's an everpresent
asterisk next to his name that being his
declining Health as it almost always at
some point impacts his work and
enthusiasm for it with YuYu hakos show
you can tell he was contending with
inspiration issues as well as a
tremendous amount of pain yet despite
this either by personal choice
obligation to jump or both he knuckled
down and brute forced his way through
the final Arc of this series and it
unfortunately shows and this is what
gave me a new appreciation for Tashi
finally enough through his transparent
output as well as the obvious struggle
this Arc was for him I have for the very
first time ever been able to look back
on my time with the Chimera an's Arc of
Hunter Hunter and say that while I can
still feel the pain and turmoil of
tashi's life flow through each page I
can now see much more than a simple man
crumbling to the depression that's
enveloping his life I can see an artist
that has grown to accept the limitations
of his body his health and his mental
state and through that acceptance
learned that just like I had to stepping
back to recover both mentally and
physically so that the artwork you go
through all this pain for is delivered
in a fashion you can be proud of and no
matter what your opinion is on yuu Haka
show whether you agree with my analysis
or or not you cannot say that tagashi
was happy with the way this series
concluded and despite the time between
chapter releases growing wider and
farther apart for Hunter Hunter with
each passing second tagashi reinforces
my belief that he's uncompromising in
his vision and love for that story and
in a way through fighting this uphill
battle against his own body and mind
learning from his mistakes with yuu Haka
Show's final Arc tagashi has become a
manga I have grown to have the utmost
respect for he's a true artist and
Visionary dedicated to delivering his
Masterpiece when his mind and body
allows and I don't think very many other
artists out there could say that they
have pushed through as much pain and
sorrow as consistently as yoshihiro
Tashi and so if and when I do return to
Hunter Hunter I won't see pain anymore
I'll see courage and I'm a little
ashamed that it took yuu Haka show to
show me that but thankfully we have
reached the end of this series and with
it we now look onto the Horizon and see
and a wait for Netflix's liveaction YuYu
Haka show will it live up to the hype or
will it spiral into chaos only one way
to find out and we'll be covering that
next
[Music]
for